okay
my hair is still soaked
okay guys i want you guys to help me
pick an outfit for tonight
i have to run like some errands and
stuff these are all my mom's dresses
like to be honest
unfort
um
is this too little house on the prairie
i don't even know
[Music]
i'm going on the show i am
no i kind of had a feeling i would go on
because i was coming down here for a
vacation anyway
so it's like i have a feeling i'm gonna
end up on the show
and i'll give you insight into what
girls have to do to get ready for things
oh my gosh but i'm low maintenance so
i'm like not
any exception not the rule most girls
take a lot longer than i do
okay
so i have a couple
outfit ideas um
so this is one okay these are all my
mom's dresses because i'm poor i'm gonna
just be honest
my mom's rich i'm poor my mom's got
dresses i don't so this is option one
um i'm gonna go change and come back
i'll be back
okay gosh
okay this is option two
but this is kind of ugly to me
maybe if i got like a belt or something
okay wait
don't do it pearl they're taking a huge
l
guys i don't care like
just because i can go like talk to
people like i
why would i care about a situation that
has nothing to do with me like honestly
um okay not number two
okay i'm coming back
okay this is option oh gosh
number three i don't think i like the
stripes again these are my mom's
um
look at it
ah this is kind of like an old style
what do you guys think
you like the first one the best okay i'm
gonna try a couple more
uh
okay
okay sorry guys
um
[Music]
oh my gosh okay i would wear different
like unders with this
um
i feel like i'm gonna look fat in this
dress
um okay
or something red the first one
just wear a hoodie
do i have anything in red i do
um
um
okay i'm gonna go try a different one
okay this one is a little too like tight
i've worn it to like a bar before but on
camera
i'm like
i like kind of prefer more modest stuff
if i'm gonna be filmed in it
[Music]
um
for real this one see
i kind of liked the first one
it's a bit too tight yeah that's what
i'm saying like i think it's just a bit
tighter than i want it to be
i'm gonna be honest guys
i'm most comfortable in this i'm like
not even gonna lie to you
high-waisted jeans
i'd have to dry the t-shirt
but like
um
let's see
hmm
am i afraid of getting kicked out no i
don't carry myself like that so i'm
i could but i don't think so
guys these jeans are starting to get a
little big on me look at that
it's my boyfriend coming i don't have a
boyfriend
yeah we broke up um
basically
basically i'm going
to
play volleyball overseas um
and we kind of both agreed that like
distance really wasn't gonna work
so
yeah so we broke up
um
there was like other stuff too but it's
not really worth like going into
um
any chance we can get the old men to
give us some
do you think i should go shopping
effort does youtube ban my videos
if um
yeah i just had to like
i don't know i had to make a decision if
i thought like it was worth like staying
for um there was just
i don't know
so but yeah that's like what happened
should i go shopping guys
you can come with me just okay when i'm
on tick tock it'll ban me
if um
it'll literally ban me if
i like go on my car
but i actually need to go to best buy
anyway so if i see something while i'm
out
because honestly like i really don't
have a lot of clothes
um
but i mean i'm not married to like going
shopping it's just like
if i if i find something out but i'm
like lazy when it comes to shopping i
hate shopping so it's more like if i
find something cool
okay i got my wallet got my phones
just ironed that shirt i don't have an
ironborn
go where don't worry your mom's stuff
get something
okay guys
okay i'm gonna give you my true opinion
on why i would still go on fresh and fit
look
people are people do i am i really gonna
like
care that much
you know like did i did i think what
they did was disrespectful sure did i
think they were wrong
yeah
i was actually gonna make a video about
it if i wasn't like traveling
um
but
it's like it's not a fight i'm in
like i'm not with this whole
people do one thing wrong and then you
can't ever talk to them again
everyone's done shitty stuff
we're human
that red is your color
i'm not gonna be a bimbo
um like to be honest guys i talked to a
guy on my channel that hooked up with
over a thousand girls
like based on what you know about me do
you think
do you think that's something that i
find to be like cool
no no i don't think that lifestyle is
good
like i think they're legit at what they
do that's why i'll talk to them but i'll
literally talk to anybody
like my mom raised me to get along with
people
okay
like
people do [ __ ] like people are people so
that's the one thing my dad has always
taught me is like
his expectations for people is literally
nothing and if you get something out of
it he's excited
but
guys i sold my car so i'm in this big
ass band this week
okay
oh my gosh where am i going
um
oh shoot i can't even live stream this
because
[ __ ]
i can't even live stream this because i
have to put in my gps but
i'm gonna talk i'm gonna
go back on live when i get to the store
um
i gotta go